bonjour merci de nous accorder un petit
peu de votre temps j'ai une première
question à vous poser vous avez passé
les 13 premières années de votre vie
Burundi c'était comment l'école là-bas
c'était une très belle école très grande
où on pouvait rentrer en maternelle et
sortir en terminale donc avec toutes les
générations dans la même enceinte
c'était aussi
très cosmopolite il y avait bien sûr des
Burundais des Rwandais des Congolais
donc des gens de la région mais il y
avait aussi beaucoup de gens de passage
allez c'était la grande époque de la
coopération française donc il y avait
beaucoup de copains en français avec
leurs enfants il y avait il y avait des
gens des instituts des institutions
internationales donc leurs enfants
étaient là il y avait d'autres
nationalités africaines donc c'est ça
c'était une école
très multicolore très bizarre
c'est une des rares photos que j'ai de
cette époque donc voilà donc quand je
parle de il y a toutes les couleurs
là je suis en CM2 là moi je suis là
juste ici voilà avec un oeil fermé il y
a trop de soleil
et voilà Monsieur Bournat qui était un
jeune prof français de 27 ans qui était
super en quoi il était super c'est pour
vous un instituteur un professeur des
écoles super il avait beaucoup d'humour
il essayait vraiment de nous mettre à
l'aise je me souviens le premier jour il
a dit bon je veux pas que vous fassiez
les pitres et il a fait le poirier tout
de suite et on était tous morts de rire
et ils nous ont emmené en classe verte
il nous faisait faire beaucoup de sport
enfin c'était vraiment c'est un prof qui
m'a marqué enfin l'instituteur qui m'a
marqué et quel type d'élèves vous étiez
très rêveur très très timide ouais à me
cacher un petit peu à toujours regarder
par la fenêtre
[Musique]
assez effacé mais intéressé par ce qui
se passait ouais justement les cours de
ce monsieur les apprentissages ça vous
parlait quand même un peu
il y a des matières que je préférais
plus que d'autres forcément l'histoire
et la géographie j'aimais bien parce que
c'était déjà on racontait des ailleurs
on me racontait
des histoires du paysage et donc ça
faisait déjà travailler l'imagination on
vous raconter déjà à ce moment là
l'histoire de votre région de je parle
du Rwanda du Burundi de cette région là
en fait de l'Afrique mais
malheureusement on ne parlait pas de
l'histoire de la région parce que moi
j'étais dans un lycée français et donc
oui on parlait de on avait le programme
français et donc ça c'est
plus tard à l'adolescence je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y avait comme une
contradiction parce que parce que on
savait pas on connaissait pas ce qui
s'était passé dans le pays quand la
guerre est apparue au Burundi
on s'est posé des questions sur
finalement d'où venait tous ces conflits
de quelle histoire on était issus et oui
je savais mieux parler de l'histoire de
France que de l'histoire du Bondier du
Rwanda un son qui vous de cette époque
un son qui me revient de cette époque
c'est les tambourinaires du Burundi
parce qu'il y avait un stade à côté de
l'école qui est le stade Roi gazoray du
prince et il y avait des entraînements
de tambourinaires donc on avait souvent
la pubsation comme ça quand on était en
classe vous expliquer vous étiez assez
timide finalement assez introverti mais
voilà est-ce que vous avez des copains
c'est une période de très très grande
amitié j'avais plein de copains on avait
pas école l'après-midi donc
c'était souvent qu'on se retrouvait
après l'école
et puis et puis voilà cette grande cour
de récréation qui permettait de
connaître tout le monde avoir des
histoires un peu avec tout le monde
c'est c'était
des personnes avec qui vous avez
toujours contact aujourd'hui oui pour
pour certaines c'est vrai que comme on a
eu un moment la guerre la guerre c'était
particulier parce que on a fermé l'école
française assez rapidement il y a eu un
il y a eu des rapatriements et donc du
jour au lendemain on s'est perdu de vue
c'était une époque avant Internet donc
on savait pas où les uns et les autres
atterrissaient on a été éparpillés dans
le monde entier et donc on a mis
beaucoup de temps à se retrouver les uns
les autres mais une fois qu'on s'est
retrouvé on a on organisé des rencontres
et puis et puis ouais on est pour
certains on est encore en contact vous
en parlez à l'instant la guerre
1993 et vous arrivez en France vous
arrivez en France à Versailles au
collège
expliquez-moi alors ce qui me vient
c'est un choc un choc
je vais dire
déjà de paysages d'un coup je passais de
cette très grande cour de récréation
avec des arbres il faisait beau toute
l'année à une toute petite cour de
récréation du béton partout des arbres
sans feuilles beaucoup de bruit parce
que d'un coup on est sur les couloirs
donc ça résonne nous on n'avait pas du
tout ça parce qu'on avait des classes
qui donnaient directement à l'extérieur
et le son se perdait et puis voilà le
manque de lumière donc moi c'est ça d'un
coup tout ça sombrit parce qu'on se lève
le matin il fait nuit on rentre de
l'école il fait nuit tout ça c'est des
choses que je ne connaissais pas et puis
aussi ben
je connais plus personne parce que ça
arrive assez brutalement donc il faut
refaire connaissance et souvent avec des
personnes qui sont pas du tout
intéressés par mon histoire par
l'endroit où je viens et donc
j'apprends aussi à m'excuser de d'avoir
de venir d'ailleurs d'avoir une autre
histoire de pas connaître les références
j'avais aussi un Français qui était lent
parce que on parlait différemment
ça c'est à dire que là déjà comment je
parle je parle très vite je parle très
vite le français
[Musique]
par rapport à la manière dont on vous la
transforme
les gens parlent le français beaucoup
plus lentement et donc
d'un coup je comprenais pas ce que les
gens disaient ça allait beaucoup trop
vite les gens aspirent les mots
galopent et donc c'était des beaucoup de
choses comme ça
c'était une période d'adaptation et
heureusement à l'adolescence on s'adapte
vite bien sûr est-ce que vous avez un
prof une prof une matière qui vous
aurait marqué au collège oui là c'est le
français avec Madame boulanger en
troisième qui commence à nous faire lire
des livres qui m'intéressent et on doit
faire des fiches de lecture on doit en
parler en classe
donc moi j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour
L'Étranger de Camus voilà
et puis
et puis Hugo Maupassant plein de textes
classiques
mais j'aimais j'aimais la douceur de
cette femme ça sa façon
de faire de transmettre sa passion même
si la note n'était pas bonne elle était
toujours encourageante et c'est les
seuls copies moi que j'ai gardé de cette
époque voilà je sais que c'est passé
quelque chose à la mort de François
Mitterrand donc le 8 janvier 1996
François Mitterrand décède et donc on
organise comme dans tous les collèges et
dans tous les établissements de France
une minute de silence comment vous vivez
ce moment je le vis très très mal je vis
très mal ce moment parce que j'ai été
menacé de mort lorsque j'étais au
Burundi avec
sous prétexte que j'étais français et
que Mitterrand avait
été le complice des génocidaires au
Rwanda
et donc c'est vrai que je vis mal d'être
associé à cette personne qu'on appelait
d'ailleurs sur place tonton machette et
[Musique]
je sens que qu'en France il est
enfin dans l'entourage dans les gens qui
en parlent c'est quelqu'un qui a du lait
on loue on loue le grand homme d'État et
moi c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai reçu
ressenti depuis l'endroit du je viens
et donc je me rends compte que qu'il y a
voilà j'ai un mal-être à
associer cette double identité française
et rwandaise et je pense que c'est un
moment assez décisif pour moi ou je vais
commencer à m'intéresser
à cette histoire à poser de plus en plus
de questions et puis et puis lorsque je
serai lycéen surtout l'année de
terminale mais là je vais vraiment
commencer à lire des livres à aller dans
des conférences à aller voir des pièces
de théâtre et vraiment à démêler
le vrai du faux et à comprendre aussi la
resp possibilité française au Rwanda si
vous replongez dans ce dans ce jour-là
il est midi il y a une minute de silence
qu'est-ce qui se passe si j'avais pu
prendre mes écouteurs et écouter ma
musique j'aurais fait non je me sentais
je me sentais vraiment
manipulé et surtout c'est cette
impossibilité après d'en discuter c'est
à dire que une fois qu'on retourne en
classe bon on a fait la minute de
silence et c'est tout moi j'aurais voulu
en parler j'aurais voulu
qu'on nous parle de cet homme qu'on nous
dise quel est son parcours qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et donc ouais je me sens je
me sens manipulé et pas du tout à l'aise
au collège est-ce que vous développez
aussi d'autres activités
des choses à côté de l'école ou pas
vraiment ou je joue beaucoup au basket
je suis dans un club de basket et puis
et puis aussi
[Musique]
n'ayant pas tant de copains que ça de
camarades je me réfugie pas mal à la
bibliothèque du quartier parce que on
peut emprunter des bouquins et puis
comme comme je commence déjà
depuis le Burundi j'écris j'écris déjà
un peu
des poèmes des nouvelles des choses
comme ça mais pour moi simplement je
commence un peu à être intéressé par par
la façon dont les autres écrivent donc
aller à la bibliothèque c'est aussi une
manière de découvrir des auteurs de
toute façon d'écrire est-ce que déjà à
l'école ou au collège
vous pensiez devenir ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui
non non
[Musique]
si jamais vous imaginez quelque chose je
m'imaginais surtout retourner vivre au
Bondy c'était ma c'était ma seule
ambition il y avait pas d'autres
alternatives il fallait que je retourne
au Bondy et que je fasse partie de cette
génération qu'elle les reconstruire le
pays c'était vraiment un objectif donc
dans cette optique là je me disais il
faut trouver un métier sérieux un métier
qui permet de reconstruire comme on dit
au Burundi enfin la région il y a un
métier de Buana quoi qui a été quelqu'un
qui qui compte artiste forcément c'est
ça c'est pas un métier sérieux
vous poursuivez jusqu'au lycée et au
lycée à Versailles toujours vous
découvrez la MJC expliquez-moi ce qui se
passe la première fois que vous passez
la porte ouais donc c'est un garçon de
ma classe et qui me parle de cette MJC
lui va danser tous les samedis et donc
on y va un samedi je l'accompagne
pensant assister voilà son cours de
danse mais il me dit quand même des gars
qui écrit donc je me dis il y a
peut-être des ateliers d'écriture et
finalement je me retrouve dans un
atelier de rap il y avait un DJ il avait
des platines
et puis il y avait il y avait un micro
et là il y avait des petits groupes de
rap et il passait des instrumentales et
les gars râpés et alors moi je trouve ça
génial j'ai jamais touché un micro de ma
vie j'ai jamais posé sur une instru donc
mais c'était pourtant de la musique que
vous écoutiez à ce moment-là ouais voilà
[Musique]
à cette époque là
donc au lycée j'écoute tu as un bon
commando donc
osmopuccino lunatique voilà X-Men tout
ça et donc et puis IAM j'aimais beaucoup
i am aussi
[Musique]
donc voilà j'étais très inspiré par ça
mais j'avais jamais vraiment raté je
rappelle pour moi dans ma chambre et
donc je me disais que c'était c'était
vraiment le moyen la possibilité de
trouver du collectif il y a un programme
spécifique à l'éducation nationale via
le réseau canopée qui s'appelle les
enfants de l'Asie ça vous parle bien sûr
il y a deux textes deux de vos textes
qui ont été choisis par ce réseau c'est
Pili-Pili sur un croissant au beurre et
lundi méchant ça vous fait quoi de
savoir que potentiellement dans tous les
collèges de France on peut étudier vos
œuvres vos textes vos chansons vos
musiques extrêmement honoré quoi c'est
extraordinaire c'est un privilège et
puis j'espère surtout que ça ça va
inspirer les élèves quoi donc du coup
lundi méchant ça fait partie des textes
qui ont été donc choisis par ce collège
de de professeur je peux vous laisser
lire ce passage là
honnête mais juste celui-ci je vais pas
me laisser démonter par bad vibes et
morosité parce qu'on tenter mais tenter
sinon tes rêves enterrer chauffer
chauffer ou être en temps les pulsations
dans tes tympans chanté chanté ce cancan
écouter lundi méchant comme un lundi
comme un lundi à lundi méchant bon ça
c'était c'était pour résister à la
morosité ambiante parce que j'ai écrit
cette chanson en plein en pleine
pandémie voilà avec avec ce qu'on
connaissait des couvre-feu des
confinements etc donc c'était aussi une
manière un peu combattante de dire bon
on va pas se laisser démonter par la
morosité moi j'ai j'ai donné ma version
de la chose après donc on lance un appel
si un prof veut se lancer dans une
chorale lyrique là-dessus
en face de vous quel message vous auriez
envie de lui faire passer en fait un
prof c'est un peu comme un artiste c'est
à dire qu'il est en face d'une classe
il a le il a verbe pour s'exprimer il a
le corps pour s'exprimer
je pense que beaucoup de choses passent
par le non verbal
et donc nous quand on monte sur scène on
sait que les spectateurs sont attentifs
à tout ce qui se passe pas seulement à
ce qui sort de notre bouche donc moi je
dirais au prof de voilà ça de réussir de
savoir être passionnant c'est ce qu'on
enfin c'est le rêve de tout de tout
Nutella Je pense c'est d'avoir un prof
passionnant merci beaucoup merci merci
[Musique]